i was supposed to go to school in
switzerland right with my dad's sister
really um so growing up there was a
point in time i think when i was like
pre-teen
the
the plan was for me to
move my sister and i to move to europe
study in europe what not
um and i think i could have had an
equally
spectacular life taken that route even
if i'd never met you guys like i believe
it could have been
something cool as well just think about
that you would not have any of the
influence of pasadena
but i've done this have you swallowed
your ethics and made a decision yeah
that [ __ ] a lot of people over
but it was still the right decision like
what example like in my life i had one
decision that was ethically kind of
ambiguous and kind of wrong
and i heard a lot of people's feelings
but it benefited me like what tell us
then you just have to live with it if
you're okay with it i'm fine with it
i'm really fine with it but well then
it's not an ethical dilemma for you i
still think about it going god what uh
well there you go what a weasel you are
you do think about it what an insect you
know what i mean so you're not okay with
it really deep down maybe i'm not but my
life would have turned out
completely different
yeah i can tell you what it is
um
but it's a long story i don't care i
want to hear it we might as well
all right
so years ago i when i started doing
stand-up right um
i didn't know paulie shore or his family
or anything like that i just was at the
comedy store and the la jolla comedy
store in san diego um
it's its own culture back in the day
right you know it's just like it has
nothing to do with really
the hollywood comedy store right in
terms of management or who
because you're a regular at the la jolla
conference it doesn't necessarily mean
you get any love in la you don't they
know who the [ __ ] you are this and that
so when i first came to the lloyd comedy
store there was this guy named fred
burns and ron clark and this guy named
um
other people i forgot i'll figure out
later um but they brought me in right
so they managed to you know fred burns
guy
he goes move into my place you know i
mean because you're struggling and he
gave me a lot of stage time and a lot of
fatherly advice and how to
do comedy and this and that and
and you know
he really is the first guy to like kind
of tell me that i am talented and tell
me that
you have a shot at this kid you know
and then three years down two years down
the road um
i met mitzi and paulie in the gang right
and they
said one day we're gonna fire fred burns
and everyone even the waitresses
everyone the club is starting anew
but we want to keep you
and i go okay but you can't
[ __ ] with them anymore
you can't talk to them you have to kind
of join our
it's [ __ ] up for them to give you an
ultimatum like that though power play
yeah yeah and i go um
okay and then i had to go to fred and
those guys uh
i'm gonna join this team
you know what i mean and they're like
what they fired everybody
so they were they started their own
club they wanted to start their own
thing scene right
and but mitzi goes
and so what happened one time was
they opened up a different club they
didn't last but mitzi wanted me to go
spy
so i went spied for mitzi
to get dormant because you need a
doorman so i went to people
at this other club to sneak to get them
to come back to the comedy store in la
jolla recruit recruit and they found out
i was spying and a comic punched me in
the face
right and i went back and i you know i
thinking back at that
i
have problems with it oh my god i like
to defend young bob i could go ahead
um you were put in a position of like
basically like that
a bunch of adults right because mitzi
was in her what at this point how old
was mitzi
no 70s how old was fred burns
50s okay these are people with let's
assume fully formed brains who can
impart wisdom on these young comics
instead they're number one requiring you
to choose a team number two preying on
the fact that you have big dreams and
comedy and making you
actually like um what do you call it
like
um like a pond yeah like they're they're
making you do their dirty work for them
all the while knowing that you're gonna
do anything to get to get to where you
want to be which is a comedian right so
it's like
how old are you 23
25
okay well still
like you probably you're different
thirty eight in two years
you're probably broke
no money yeah no money you probably were
not doing well in life well no because
at that point what happened was you know
paulie and
mencia
i was opening for them on the road yeah
right and also mitzi had made me a paid
regular
right and you know
there was no one in san diego at the
time that was a paid regular i don't
think that was weasley only because you
went with the decision that you thought
was best for your career and we all have
to prioritize ourselves at some point
even if it means hurting their feelings
now like you know an apology down the
road would have been like hey dude
that's kind of they both died
so you never apologized no they both
died but did you make the right did you
choose the correct team
i chose the team
to lead me to here
you know and i i if i feel like if i
didn't choose that make that decision
i'd still be in san diego you you chose
i might be a better person or i feel
freer i don't know but
i you know i look back at it all the
time and i go is there any other option
and i didn't because it's like i had no
money i had no power
and i um i went to
the direction where i thought was gonna
you know i mean get me these
opportunities now
it sounds it's yeah it is it's like
ethically weird and and i feel
like a weasel you know you're not the
only one though there it seems like
everyone what would you have done
um probably the same thing because like
they're you weren't screwing over their
careers necessarily that was all they
were already getting fired by mitzi they
were already
you were also they were already stuck in
san diego so you're also not the sole
reason why their business went under
like
you were able to sense at that age that
this was probably not going to take you
somewhere because something about it you
know was either on its way out going
down and you were like i'm gonna
take this ride instead because this
seems like up you know yeah
i was the only comic down there also
with that option
like if other comics had that option and
they were regulars and they and mitzi
had asked them like join
the dark side or you know i mean the
light
yeah i mean or whatever i don't know
what just join yeah join
you know i mean i think that other
people would have done that but i was
the only one given that opportunity
right
but the problem was i was still living
at fred's basement right so when i did
made that decision i could hear them
through the vents
no i really did i'm not kidding that's
why i moved to l.a because i i remember
hearing through the vans
that [ __ ] we're gonna [ __ ]
get that guy you know i mean like
talking about you about me oh my god
right and i'm like laying there like
late at night going it was terrible i
remember i would get boils on my face
and i remember one time i was at the
panic and during that time and my friend
alan meadows from high school met me for
coffee and he goes dude you look like
[ __ ]
i look like [ __ ] i i couldn't sleep you
know you know me i'm so sensitive i was
like frazzled i'm like i think they're
going to kill me i i have no allies here
and that's when i decided i go
i think i called mencia and i go can you
help me with money to get me to la i
think he gave me a couple hundred bucks
to come up i don't know something like
that and i moved up and i lived um in a
my friend kalista was in la but i
i slept in my um truck
in the comedy store parking lot for a
couple of weeks because you were scared
that's when i moved up here and that's
when jimmy schubert gave you a sample
give me a sandwich that's when that
happened but my point is is that it was
like
[ __ ]
terrible
and then coming up here i couldn't get
anything going you know i mean no money
nothing was so hard i just can't believe
i survived all that but i still think
about that decision and i go what could
i have done differently i don't think
there is any other
option i was given
a choice and i made a decision
but you know i feel i don't know
what have you done
honestly
i don't think
i mean
in terms of auditioning i feel early on
there was some stuff where i probably
didn't um
i was available to help some people do
self tapes
and i said nah